اهلا نعود اليكم من امام احد الابراج
الواقع في مدينه رياض تحديدا طريق الملك
فهد والذي يبلغ طوله 120 متر وكما نرى
تتزين هذا البرج بصوره المؤسسه الملك عبد
العزيز رحمه الله وتعد الجداريه الاكبر في
العالم وينضم اليها للحديث اكثر عن
التفاصيل هذه الجداريه الفنان محمد العمار
الذي قام برسمها اهلا بك محمد همم بدايه
حديثنا كيف اتت فكره رسم هذه الجداريه
خصوصا على هذا البرج بهذه الضخامه هل تم
التخطيط لها مسبقه
اولا صباح الخير ااا ثانيا ااا الحمد لله
يعني الفكره كانت انه ما كنت انا ابغى
ارسم على جداريه عملاقه مثل البرجه لكن
الخطه اني انا ارسم على برج ارسم على
الجدار جدار عملاق
همم بالتخطيط مع الاداره نفس اللي هي
نفسها اداره البرج قالوا لي انه احنا
حابين نسوي الكلادينج هذا
اللي هي رسمه جداريه
فقلت لهم اوكي ما يخالف اللي هي نفسها
اداره المهدي
خلص ما يخالف
اخذ مني وقت ممكن
اسبوعين على بال ما اني انا اتخذ قرار
يعني انه انا اوكي اقدر اسويها ولا لا
ولكن الحمد لله همم اخذت قرار وخطط لها
اه محمد حدثني عن نوع الجدار اول
السطح الذي قمتم بتنفيذ الرسمه عليه وما
هي الادوات المستخدمه في تنفيذ هذه الرسم
الواجهه هناك قزاز اللي على الشارع العام
اللي على الدائري والجدار نفس اللي انا
رسمت عليه
الغازيه اللي هي الالوان الغازيه الوان
الرسامين يعني بشكل عام اللي هو البخاخات
اللي جرى فيها
طيب حدثني محمد عن مراحل تنفيذ العمل من
هو فريق العمل كيف يعني نفذتهم هذه
الجداريه صعودا ام نزولا اا كيف وصلتم
للقمه وما هي الادوات التي تم استخدامها ل
صعود
بالنسبه للناس اللي جت ساعدتني ما في احد
انا كنت لحالي ما احد كان موجود وهو
يساعدني بالجداريه هذه همم بديت فيها من
فوق
نزولا الى تحت الى اخر الشيء لان اللي هو
تشوفونه
وما كان في اي شخص انه ساعدني فيه اللهم
ما كان اللي هو تيم ال ال ال
الاداره نفسها هم اللي علموني كيف اني انا
اطلع وانزل على الونش اللي هو الادوات
تقدر تسموه الونش الكريم هم بس علموني كيف
اني انا اطلع وانزل عليه بحيث انه مثلا لو
احتجت شيء ولا شيء اني انا اتواصل معهم لا
مثلا صار اطول فني ولا كده بس
محمد العمري
جزيلا شكرا ونرحب فيك من ضمن فريق صباح
العربيه هذا ظهورك الاول على برنامج صباح
العربيه في شاشه العربيه شكرا لك
صباح العربيه